hi nice to see you both nice to see you
Nepal
congratulations this is a really fun day
to be able to celebrate with fans have
you been surprised by the reaction that
you've gotten from fans all over the
world oh yes yeah
tremendously I mean it's just it's like
when I was on laugh-in and and the world
was much more fragment and now but you
know any place I go someone says hold
Frankie Frankie and oh god this and
how's grace and all that stuff and it's
just like being like Ernestine you know
answer that phone Ernestine yeah I I
agree I've been to a number of other
countries outside of the US in the last
year and you say grace and Frankie and
people applaud they love it I love it if
season 5s mantra was it what is season 6
mantra rise up rise up I remember that
rise up Baron said ooh well that's very
that's how Baron communicated
I have this beautiful photo of both of
you I'd love for you to hold it up and
tell me what advice would you give to
your younger selves
take chances make mistakes be messy take
leaps of faith is this friendship
stronger now than it was then
oh yeah much stronger yeah I mean it's
just more you know what it is with age
comes wisdom so you know who's a good
friend to have you had some answer what
would you say Jane to what she's very
important to me and and I think our
friendship is stronger now than it was
we know each other better we've been
working together now for six years
better yeah
god help us you had so many amazing
guest stars in season five RuPaul and
Nicole Richie who can we expect for
season six I don't think we're supposed
to say well I heard Michael Sheehan well
true any rumor there's rumors about Dali
coming on potentially yeah well we we
always try we try every year and we want
her on she wants to be on she's just
super busy is that does that involve one
of you picking up the phone and calling
her yeah sometimes yeah both of this
yeah it's a conference calling or when
I'm counseling her on her career I say
when she wants to try it a lyric on me
and I say I'd change the that active to
proactive
you're a good friend yeah well
congratulations ladies thank you so much
have fun in there today nice to meet you
about you're both legends